Marilyn Manson
the the famous rock star
Satanist weirdo guy is accused of
sexually assaulting a 16 year old on a
tour bus and threatened to kill that
woman's family this apparently in the
1990s so it was a long time ago I know
with a lot of these stories when they
just happened to come out 30 years later
it it makes us all a bit skeptical of it
especially because a lot of these people
are just seeking money and they're you
know at different points in their life
you say why didn't why didn't the story
come out sooner
in this story though I think Marilyn
Manson actually had talked about it in
the past I think in a different time in
a different era Marilyn Manson kind of
bragged about some of these things I I'm
I don't have anything really to say
about the story other than it's always
the ones you most expect